some people will be looking at what
happened yesterday and thinking the
Prime Minister have brought a deal back
so why do we need another extension I
didn't vote for an extension what I
voted for was an insurance policy all I
did was support all of electron's
Amendment because I want to make sure
that we leave with a deal not no deal
which is what the original intent of the
Ben Act was and all this does is try to
protect that initiative so I support the
Prime Minister's deal and I have told
him I will support it next week I
understand people's fatigue let me tell
you I suffer from it myself but we have
to make sure that we don't leave with no
deal the Prime Minister's got this deal
he thought I mean at one point he said
he didn't think he could get a deal with
the EU unless he had no deal as a threat
but in fact the Ben Act removed no deal
as a threat and he got this deal and I
want to support it and I will and I
think not all of us but most of us it's
on the conserve former conservative
former conservatives who supported the
latwon amendment will do so as well
interesting to hear that you will be
supporting and yeah do when it comes
back and I have told the Prime Minister
that and I you know it's quite possible
we will still leave by October 31st but
I think it's absolutely right to say we
don't want to leave with no deal but we
do want to leave with a deal and this
deal from the prime minister is good
enough for me if you say you need an
insurance policy against no deal who is
it that you don't trust do you not trust
the Prime Minister or do you not trust
some of your former colonies any group
of MPs could bring an amendment and try
and get a coalition around it so that it
could stop it moving forward the
legislation that we need to actually
leave and if you just have the threat of
no deal hanging over then it won't allow
us to be able to debate them or spend
time trying to win over the argument and
that could just allow us to trip over
once more into No Deal the Prime
Minister has got us a deal and I have
congratulated him for that the whole
purpose of this amendment is not to try
and have a delay but to try and make
sure that we don't leave without a deal
so it's the European research group
effectively it's not no it could be it
could be a group of Labour MPs it could
be any more unlikely business it's a
very fragile coalition to support the
Prime Minister's deal and can I say
something else I regret very much the
fact that the Prime Minister did not
allow us to vote on his deal after the
latwon amendment I had expected to I was
going to support it and I think he would
have seen then that he has a fragile but
sincere coalition of people who want to
support it so the reason that they
didn't bring that forward was because of
the lack wind and then moon I mean it
deleted a lot of most of the things that
made the vote meaningful it did one
thing which is it said that we can only
leave with a deal which is what the ban
Act had already said it said we couldn't
negate the pen act until we had had the
legislation through in support of his
deal it's a very reasonable proposal and
I wish that afterwards we've been able
to show our support for the actual
proposal the Prime Minister's brought
forward I just wonder if people looking
at what happened in Parliament yesterday
will be thinking that actually this is
all about MPs trying to thwart breck
said it's not about getting a deal it's
not about ruling out no deal it's about
more delay it's about staying in
purgatory longer I know that that is the
spin that is being put out by people who
just say just get it done but this is
such an important event getting this
treaty right I don't think it is
unreasonable to allow MPs to look at it
we haven't even seen the legislation yet
you know as Justin greening pointed out
very wisely yesterday the annual budget
is scrutinized for months now this is
something which is going to be permanent
for the UK it's not unreasonable that
MPs take their responsibilities
seriously we're not a rubber stamp
organisation and look carefully at the
legislation as it goes through well
let's talk about the what's on the table
shall we do you think this is a deal
that's better or worse than the one that
Therese arm a negotiator I don't think
it's as good as Teresa Mays deal I
regret the fact that we don't have
effectively a backstop for the whole of
the country instead it's only Northern
Ireland that has not a backstop but as
some people put it a front stop that
board is going to be open and there's
several supporters of the bill have said
it's a great deal for Northern Ireland
apart from the Union element which is
quite a big element which is in terms of
the economy it's very good for Northern
and it's less good for the rest of the
Union so I thought that Teresa Mays deal
was the right deal I think this is not
as good but I want I will nevertheless
support it my biggest concern about it
is
the union and you know the major parties
from Scotland and from Northern Ireland
both heavily opposed it I think that's a
problem but nevertheless I think that we
should go ahead with it we've got to win
the argument and we've got to make sure
that we move on from here that I do
agree with I mean you can see that the
DP have had some quite consistent red
lines throughout this yeah on protecting
the Union they feel that this undermines
it yeah and are you worried about their
concerns as Boris Johnson sold out his
former allies I am worried about their
concerns I think anybody who describes
themselves as a conservative and
unionist will be worried about their
concerns but the Prime Minister has
shown great flexibility and he's decided
to prioritize getting this deal done
there is more work to do to try and
reassure the DUP and I'm not sure that
we will be able to achieve that and I
just wonder as well are you talking
about the threat of No Deal
one thing that struck me from the event
say the last few days were comments made
by John Barron Conservative MP who says
he can vote for the deal because it
leaves open in his mind the prospect of
a No Deal next year and Philip Hammond
on Friday at one of your colleagues
haven't come this far seeking to avoid
no deal in 2019 to be duped into voting
for heavily camouflage no deal at the
end of 2020 yes I kept no idea they were
being duped I think that most of us are
looking at it with with a certain amount
of realism this is a start to the brexit
process to a large degree the idea that
it's all done when this deal goes
through is completely wrong there's a
lot more to negotiate and do but I think
actually that the Prime Minister has
shown that he's willing to have a closer
relationship with the European Union
that he might have telegraphed during
some of his campaigning previously and I
take great comfort from what why do you
say that because many people will look
at this deal and the concern that they
will have is that they will see a looser
relationship with the EU being proposed
and that under Teresa well it isn't
that's what John McDonald was eight
years ago sir but under Teresa may but
it is not as loose as WTO or the sort of
stuff that Nigel Farage wants it is
indeed a compromise which is why I
support it I would like to see the
regulatory alliances the regulatory
alignment element in the withdrawal
agreement as it had been under Teresa
may making sure that goods are breaking
in the same way across the EU and across
the UK so how much do you think that
hurt the economy and if they still does
go our own government's own assessments
are that it will hurt the economy I
think by four to six percent yeah so
it's serious stuff but I still think
that it's the right thing to do because
we had the referendum in 2016 and
there's other steps we can take to try
and mitigate that I'm not a huge
enthusiasm Suzy asked for brexit but I
do believe that we have a as someone who
campaigned very hard in 2016 to remain a
very conscious of the fact that the
public voted to leave and I want to help
achieve that every move I've done since
then has been to try to do that and I do
point out to some of our critics those
of us who voted for the amendment that
many of us have voted to leave the
European Union more times in the prime
minister has it's pretty clear that you
will back the deal even though you have
reservations about it yes what happens
next week it could really come down to
the former conservative rebels that the
MPs who were stripped to the
Conservative Party whip how do you think
how many do you think will support the
deal I think that it you can probably
see quite clearly if you look at the
people who supported the amendment that
there are many of us myself Oliver let
win himself and a few others who have
said that they just want to make sure
that the threat of No Deal is removed
they will support the Prime Minister's
deal there are a few others who have
taken a different view but I think there
is a coalition for getting the Prime
Minister's deal through I'd also do you
think do you think it will get through I
do think it will go through I also point
out there are several Labour MPs who
have said they will support the Prime
Minister's legislation now because they
amendment got through so some of us who
supported it although I know everybody
makes their own case for their own moves
will would say that it helps the
legislation get through because it
protects that coalition now when you
resigned from Boris Johnson's cabinet I
just won't have a little look at what
you said in your letter to him we can
have a little look now you said I no
longer believe leaving with a deal is
the government's main objective the
government is expending a lot of energy
to prepare for No Deal but I have not
seen the same level of intensity go into
our talks with the European Union well
he's come back with a deal in a
breakneck speed that many people thought
was in
possible should you now be apologizing
to the Prime Minister no I have
congratulated the Prime Minister but I
do think the Prime Minister has
surprised many of us by breaking what
were a number of his red lines before
and the response from the DUP has really
been the evidence for that the fact that
they still want to the government to
leave No Deal on the table and rush
through this legislation over the next
10 days really confirms what I've said
that is that there's so much effort into
preparation for no deal where is the
work not only in going and getting the
deal but in selling the deal to the
House of Commons but he has got the deal
mascot idea and I as I say I
congratulate every studio we've been in
touch but owned only by text refer to
say the text makers that are private but
they are very constructive listen the
Prime Minister is familiar with the
route of resigning over a point of
principle from cabinet I think that we
all know he did it once himself so do
you hope that there may be a route back
to the Conservative Party Whip
if rating Fidel possibly but Sophie like
many of my colleagues I am very much to
prioritize what I believe is best for
the country not necessarily best for the
party but you would retake the web if it
was offered
well I surrendered the whip voluntarily
so I think it's a different process for
me but I am doing what I believe is
right for the country in the national
interest and at the next election why
are you planning to stand I'm still
thinking about it
I haven't decided yet but rest assured
I'll let you know